the fast and furious franchise currently
boasts nine movies and is quite simple
to follow throw in the spin-offs
prequels and animated series and things
start to get a little more complicated
complicated like going from preschool to
kindergarten the fast saga is easy
mindless fun with more subpar movies
than great ones but it's still a
cinematic adventure what's not easy to
follow is a never-ending yet always
entertaining feud between fast pioneer
vin diesel and fashionably late to the
franchise dwayne johnson the red notice
star famously joined the fast and
furious saga for his fifth installment
entitled fast five and fit in as much as
a six foot five 260 pound monstrosity
can johnson portrays luke hobbs in the
universe a faux turned friend of dominic
toretto and the fast family all seemed
great between the actors until 2016 when
johnson posted a lengthy caption on
instagram calling some male co-stars
candy asset in the now deleted post
johnson made it clear he did not see eye
to eye with one of his colleagues and it
was rather evident he was talking about
diesel this was just after the
production of fate of the furious and
johnson did not return for f9 amidst the
drama for the last five years diesel and
johnson have gone back and forth on
social media and in interviews giving
their size of the story which never
seemed to match up the most recent
update came in the form of an olive
branch from diesel to johnson through
yet another instagram post with the
former begging his old friend to return
to the franchise for the next film it
got us thinking is this all out of the
good of diesel's heart or has this all
been carefully orchestrated the last we
heard of the feud before vin diesel's
recent instagram plea was from dwayne
johnson while he was promoting jungle
cruise in july the actor upset fast fans
worldwide when he revealed he would not
be joining any more films on the
franchise but wish those involved in the
next two projects well with diesel
confirming in an interview with regal
that filming for fast 10 and fast 11
would begin in january 2022 it seems
like his recent stunt is a little too
perfect reaching out to someone who just
put a nail in the coffin on their
participation seems like a waste of time
or a very bold and hopeful strategy
something about all this just feels
staged like diesel might be setting up
the comeback no one saw coming but in
reality we are all seeing it clear as
day with just a few months to go before
filming begins now would be the time to
solidify johnson's appearance in the
upcoming films which is supposed to be a
two-part finale to one hell of a 20-plus
year ride f9 definitely didn't feel
quite the same without johnson and
there's no doubt fast 10 and fast 11
would feel much more complete with him
did vin diesel do this out of the
kindness of his own heart it's hard to
say but we're guessing there are several
cooks in this kitchen and multiple
people likely have encouraged diesel to
make amends with his former pal there's
a lot of money to be made with these
final two fast films and the more star
power the better diesel's pose seems a
little bit over the top and especially
dramatic as he keeps suggesting it's
johnson's destiny to play hops in these
final films while the silly wording
definitely seems to fall in line with
other posts shared by the relic actor
we're not quite sure he's the only one
who felt this kind of public plea was
necessary somebody might be forcing him
to do so in 2019 johnson shared a video
to instagram where he thanked diesel for
his support of the fast and furious
spin-off film hobbs and shaw and said
with a wink i'll be seeing you soon
tireto fans thought this was the end of
their feud and it might as well have
been this makes diesel's new post all
the more confusing it looks like the men
were always primed to reunite so this
all seems like some weird fast 10
foreplay we won't be surprised to hear
the official confirmation that johnson
will return as hobbs in the next movie
and possibly fast eleven with the former
wrestler as active on social media as he
is it's somewhat surprising he hasn't
responded just yet this only further
suggests this is all being carefully
orchestrated by others behind the scenes
so johnson can react adequately we
suspect we'll get the official
confirmation that duo has reunited to
film the finale hopefully in the next
month look we're not mad about this
we're just wise to the game your move
johnson check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite tv shows and
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you